شر بس
سمعت مشتا اسمع صوته مشتاقه لامي يعني
امبارح انا جبت طحين لاولادي طلع مخلوط
اكل دواب واكل حمام ما زبط معاي في
العجين انا صبين الكتناني متزوجه من اسامه
الكتناني معاي ولد وبنت جوو وجواد انا
اسمي ام جلال سويركي ساكنه في فع بحب
الدنيا كل شي بنحب والله هلقيت انا بيجيلي
شهرين في المستشفى كنا في المدرسه صلاح
الدين وقصفوا لنا اياها يعني الطفل انا
عندي جواد او جدي بدهم يروحوا على الحمام
بحقو حالهم اضطريت اعمل لهم سطل عشان يعني
يقضوا حاجتهم فيه احنا والله اقول لك بردك
الوضع ما هو امان يعني احنا قاعدين في
غرفه ولاده توليد في غرف التوليد والله
المجاري بتطوف علينا واحنا نايمين بقوم
لفراش ميه مجاري الضل ربينا فيها وجمد
ابويا الله يرحمه وويا بيجي 70 نفر
طر انا لما رحت دخت دخت لما شفت الدار
المكان ضيق عندي وال يعني الغرفه اللي انا
قاعده فيها كذا عيله فيها مش لحالي كذا
عيله فيها لكن انا واولادي على جنب قاعدين
مبعدين عن الناس كليا الغرفه ما فيها باب
احنا حاطين ستاره والشباك ما في شباك
حاطين نايلون على الشباك والسقعه يعني هي
بتخش علينا الشتاء هديك الهار فات علينا
جوا بالغرفه وغرقنا ميه حتى الاولاد ما
كان لهم معاي ملابس صيت اشحط من الناس
عشان البسهم والله العيشه سوق الوضع صعب
ميه فش اكل فش طحين فش انا هون فاتحه باب
مرزق خبز هل بصح له حبط طحين بعجنهم بيجي
بخبزه باقل اقل حاجه يعني مساعده مع الناس
مساهمه مع العالم اللي بب انه طلعنا احنا
معنا فلوس معنا مصاري معنا نصرف معنا نجيب
اي وسيله ناكل وفي حاجات احتياطيه للنساء
و للبنات مش موجوده اننا بضطر يعني كلينس
يعني امبارح انا جبت طحين لاولادي طلع
مخلوط اكل دواب واكل حمام ما زبط معاي في
العجين الغرفه عننا ثلج وبدون حمام فيها
وعندي الاولاد بمرض انا عندي الولد والبنت
ازمه في صدرهم نهجه مستمره
والحمد لله يعني علاجهم اللي حتى الان مش
متوفر معاي ولا قادره اني اشتري علاج
النهجه لهم والله نظافه ما في نظافه احنا
يعني تقريبا هي لنا شهرين في المستشفى كل
تحممنا مره واحده في المستشفى من قله
الشامبو قله الميه بعدين الميه هان ميه
بحر مالحه يعني الطفل لما بحمم فيها بصير
صي يا ماما عيني صاروا فلفل يقوللي والله
بالنسبه للاهل انا ي شهرين
شر
بسمت مش
اسمع
مشتاج كلهم
بالجنوب اليوم ما بدات
الحرب اخر يوم جمعت فيهم في س ع والله
اللحظه هذ ما شفت شي بس الوقت هذا جابرنا
ان نشتي يعني نقعد جابرنا جابرنا لازم
نضحي اذا ما عملنا هيك ماعش لازم يكون
اقوى من الوقت اللي احنا بنمر فيه والله
نفسي اني ارجع على بيتي واعيش فيه مستوره
زي ما كنت بالاول لو بقعد فوق الرقم اني
ارجع خلص انا تعبت من هالحياه هذه والله
انا بنام يعني ليله ليله اتمنى اصحى
يقولوا وقفت
الحرب يعني يوم يوم كحلم انا اقول لك يمكن
عايشه في حلم للحظه هذه انا يمكن بحلم
بحلم مش مصدقه انا في الوضع اللي احنا فيه
بصحى كليوم على اني اساس اني اصحى من
النوم خلص ترجع الدنيا لطبيعتها وفيش شيء
فش حاجه نكون في ادات بال الكل روح لبيته
لداره نرجع للعيشه اللي كنا عايشينها في
الاول